[Music]
welcome back you are not mr. marbles
marbles looks different this week hi
Kermit has positioned his body on this
tiny little toy okay I knew I couldn't
trust you
you acted like you wanted to come up
here so bad the table
you're acting like someone who wakes up
and doesn't read this skin Wow really
did you use that as a segue really
welcome back to the journal Julien
podcast this episode is brought to you
by the scam it's a newsletter that's
completely free right in your inbox
every morning with all the top news
stories that you need to know to go
about your day and be educated beasts go
to this skim that's th es ki mm comm
slash annejulien and to your email and
subscribe also guys Squarespace if
you're building the website do it with
Squarespace they make it incredibly easy
what are you looking at they have
amazing customer support and right now
you get 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain when you go to
Squarespace calm slash annejulien or
click the link below also me undies put
some mayonnaise on your bum you won't
regret it though the best underwear I've
ever put on and I love them we both love
them they just sent us a Star Wars yeah
very cool go to me undies Emme UND is
calm slash jena Julian and you get 50
reserved for first pair in free shipping
thanks mother this is not mr. marbles in
case you're wondering if you're watching
and not listening this is Kermit
it's a specimen are you happy bud you
finally get it to be all about you
all you all about you bunnies sitting
quietly in the corner bunny is doing so
well she's sitting right here we're back
from vacation
Welbeck Beach we made it I know I've put
up a video and so is Julian so far and
we have streams so you know I know you
guys know that we're back we've been
it's our first podcast back yeah which
by the way like I it was super confusing
and it's like our fault
but I didn't expect it to be as
confusing as it was so like
we record the podcast on Thursday /
Friday mostly Thursdays and then the
following Monday it goes up so before we
left for vacation we recorded our last
podcast and then we're on vacation and a
podcast goes live and you guys are there
we got so many comments and tweets that
are like you guys didn't have to do this
while you're on vacation well thank you
I didn't know you're gonna and I'm like
damn it we timed it wrong master while
back we don't have a podcast up so it's
kind of hard sometimes to schedule that
because you know like we we can't really
podcast like weeks in advance otherwise
sometimes it doesn't make sense
ya know sometimes it doesn't make sense
because you got it sometimes it works we
have done it like weird we have but also
I think the last time we did that we
weren't streaming on Twitch you guys
talk to us everyday yeah it's like you
know and shits old or whatever yeah but
anyway like the comments that we're like
our parents went out of town but y'all
left us pizza money regards I was
putting up an thought guys yeah yeah
we're back from vacation
how was your vacation Julian my vacation
was good it was it was totally a new
experience I think for both of us but at
least it's like oh yeah at least for me
like I've never done anything like that
so it was really relaxing and it was
nice to just kind of you know getting to
like our own little routine we went to
Maui by the way there's my first time in
Hawaii
your second mm-hmm yeah I've only been
to Oahu before and I went for a marine
ball back in the day it was like a thing
to ask people to go to your marine ball
or your army whatever you know they have
forms or dances yeah I asked celebrities
like Mila Kunis and somebody asked
Justin Timberlake so I was super
flattered a kid named Danny asked me to
go to his marine ball with him via
YouTube and I was like of course I'll go
with you and he's like I'm in Hawaii you
know it was like oh my god yeah I mean I
already said yes then I'm super down yes
I went to Oahu I went to Waikiki and
then this was my first time on another
island in Hawaii and we went to Maui
mm-hmm and we did not go to a marine
ball we stated a resort and we just
chilled I mean it was it was nice like
we we found about like a mile a little
less than a mile away from ours are
there was like this walk that we would
take to this little shopping center
where it had like a burger joint that
had a beyon burger which kind of saved
us because you'd be surprised it's like
at a resort kind of environment it's a
little hard to find food for us well
yeah I mean that's true of anywhere I
think to say that one of the places that
had the most options for us as well but
you know vegan and gluten-free is a tall
order for anywhere so yeah we did end up
you know getting some groceries and
bringing them back to our hotel room
even kina playing jelly sandwiches I
think something that I learned because
you guys know we don't really take
vacations I mean we might do like a
weekend in Big Bear like a couple days
we usually take the dog so it's usually
somewhere we can drive and we're with
the dogs and it's just you know not a
long period of time so that was the
first time that wasn't Christmas in New
Year's that we've taken time off and
even in Christmas and New Year's we're
either traveling to go see my family or
they're sitting they're all here yeah
and for those of you that have families
know that sometimes spending time with
your family isn't really a vacation no
it was the first time that we've really
taken you know just a dedicated week off
which to me the most important thing was
to take a week off of work and you know
sometimes they take off my radio show or
we've taken off podcasts in the past but
to have an entire week dedicated to
nothing but just like enjoying life and
you know removing yourself from your
current location where we live and work
at home so it does you know it gets kind
of it's wild it's the dream I love
living and working you know my favorite
thing I love being with the dogs all day
that's like all I want in life but I
think years just go by without you ever
taking time for yourself as a person or
as two people you know just just friends
and like going and having some time for
yourselves and not having to work and it
was really I don't know we never ever
ever do that and it felt really good
yeah literally yours do go by and they
did go by and like where am i how old am
i what am i doing stepping on keyboards
but don't step on this keyboard that's
what he does to me when I'm gaming I
walk in you keyboarding them yeah there
was like a period when we got there
where I feel like we both were kind of
just like okay now what you know like
because we're so used to when we travel
like all right what are we here for yeah
we are so I'm gonna go see him work
today when we travel what was the event
like where's Rome like we kind of like
the first day and a half two days we
were like kind of dealing with that we
were like okay there's nothing to do we
just got to relax I was okay with that
you on the other hand I struggled with
it yeah which should be no surprise to
most you guys who know me okay there's
no more bed I don't know what you're
digging for this is it he's gonna turn
around just let him do his thing
oh yeah like I was like you know I was
struggling with like slowing down
everything right like for me a day off
or us or like a relaxing day I wouldn't
call a vacation but like a day off of
you know in my mind is like you eat good
food you watch some TV you play some
video games but at no point are you like
doing nothing mm-hmm you know what I
mean you're not like sitting on the
beach or in the pool looking out in the
beach weather during it like even just
like the the vacation sort of behavior
was new to me so I had to like adjust to
it but once I did I was like really
enjoying myself and I think that like it
was nice I mean I wouldn't say that the
people who were saying the same resort
as us were anything like us but it
didn't matter because we were kind of
just like keeping to ourselves and we
would go out to dinner sometimes or we
would eat in sometime so we would go out
to the pool sometimes or we would just
take a walk sometimes and it's like I
just think that the best part of the
vacation was getting
to just like be away from our normal
situation but like be with you I'm like
just hang I think something that I knew
about myself but got reconfirmed on the
vacation is that I am so good at doing
nothing I am it my one of my many
talents you know is just I am an
incredible at wasting time incredible at
it I can kill [ __ ] hours in the blink
of an eye I can do nothing so hard so
much
I do not care and I said to Julian - you
know before you went on this vacation
like I don't care if all we do is sit in
the hotel room and not work that's I
just want to make sure that we get this
week to like not you know be doing a
million things and I can waste so many
hours I can waste them some of those
days men flew by it was like wow I
really [ __ ] wasted all day that's not
because I am so good at yeah and you're
over there like every hour is like
crawling by like what is this nothing
what is this well yeah I mean like oh
okay so I got food poisoning while we
were out in Hawaii and which is crazy
because we've traveled to a lot of
places and neither of us have gotten
it's really sick and of course it
happened on vacation yeah I got
violently ill I was throwing up for like
five hours straight I thought we were
gonna get a noise complaint
it started at 4:00 in the morning Julian
throwing up because he had eaten
something the night before so you were I
woke up at 4:00 in the morning and you
Julian when he started opening we he
throws up he's also yelling at the same
I don't know how to throw up without
yelling I think I think that's how Wow
I've ever [ __ ] heard I'm pretty sure
that's how you throw up I do not yell
when I throw up what you're saying not
that there's anything wrong throwing up
yeah I haven't thrown up in years not
come with me no I do not yell when I
throw up you yell I scream so loud but
it's um it's a very visceral experience
for me I don't really know that I'm
yelling I just like afterwards I know
that I know
but anyway rewind run a little bit right
so we were we went out to dinner so it
kind of sucks right like we found this
restaurant that was really accommodating
they had a whole bunch of gluten-free
options vegan options it was great
it was a beautiful Italian restaurant
like really good food so he went there
once and we were we had our minds blown
by this like arrabbiata pasta really I
was so good yeah so then we went again
pushed our luck and I got a pizza this
time which I didn't get the first time
and I'm pretty sure that's what got me
sick something in the pizza like my body
rejected it's just marinara sauce but
there's also chance that it was one of
the drinks I got that had some who knows
cuz I was drinking mojitos the whole day
and night which I'm probably never gonna
drink a mojito again but you weren't
throwing up from alcohol like that no it
wasn't like it was nothing like over
drinking I've done that but it's there
was nothing like that in fact I went to
bed pretty sober yeah but anyway yeah we
pressed our luck I'm pretty sure it was
the pizza took home woke up for him
vomited for five hours to like 9:10 a.m.
they went to the urgent care yeah I was
like we got to go somewhere because I
took a dream I mean threw it up I'm like
I can't even keep anything down
no I was trying everything and it got to
the point where I was starting to feel
like I was just slowly dying you know
you can't like ingest anything and
you're draining your body so inter
urgent care they were incredible like
the best urgent care I've ever been to
they gave me a high so friend as soon as
I walked in there like here this will
help you with your Naja and it did and
they gave me Pedialyte pops they were
very very good and then the rest of the
day I was just kind of resting and yeah
that was like a we scrapped that day for
the vacation which well cuz we went to
bed at like a 1 and then you started
throwing up at like 4:00 a.m. so we only
got like exhaust a few hours of sleep
and then from 4 a.m. until we went to
Urgent Care at like 11:00 a.m. you were
sick and throwing up and scream vomiting
I was throwing up no anywhere near us in
the hotel no one was sleeping and then
we went to Urgent Care we were there for
several hours and then we came home
somebody took a nap that afternoon and
yeah yeah definitely
took an entire day
but then we didn't really drink anything
for the rest of the trip yeah I leave I
was really recently drank like a couple
days ago for the first time since that
happened I it was it was kind of gnarly
like I was especially cuz I didn't know
what exactly what it was I was like I'm
just gonna not do a lot of stuff it's
not my body for a couple days
but yeah anyway like that was a day that
we had to spend and I'm doing that but
then the next day we took a car we
rented a Jeep Haleakala yeah which was
really cool we drove all the way up to
the peak or just 10,000 feet above sea
level you're above the clouds
it was [ __ ] beautiful watch sunset up
there that was the best day for me
because we like listen okay we stayed in
a really nice place in Maui and when we
were there I think there's a lot of
people that really enjoy that you know
like people that love cruise ships
people that love like big hotels where
you walk down you get dressed up and
people buy lots of clothes for the
vacation to like you know it's a whole
thing
yeah and they go eat at the really nice
seafood and steak restaurants and you
know they get really nice breakfast by
the beach like it's a whole thing that
people really like but for me something
that I found was kind of difficult was
when you're alone as much as we are like
we're here in this house together and
you know we play video games with our
friends online but like we go to the gym
we see a trainer and you go to jujitsu
but like we're not really interacting
person to person a ton with other people
and to go from a space where you're like
mostly alone all the time even though a
lot of people see you to a place where
you're surrounded by people constantly
really doesn't feel like a vacation you
know like somehow feels like we're at
the DMV all the time I'm like oh my god
that's [ __ ] crazy down there dude is
wild there's so many people yeah
especially when I kind of feel like
everyone around us was very different
than us in a way of like their
lifestyles just nothing like ours yeah I
don't want to get dressed up on vacation
I want to wear my pajamas and like do
nothing like I think the
culture of where we were not I'm not
talking about Hawaii I'm talking about
the culture of like the resort was very
much like you know where your good
clothes and walk around and be a fancy
person yeah and we did our best to try
and find a place that would be good for
us to stay but like it's a good learning
experience about us that like I am NOT
have never been and will never be a
person that likes to relax dressed up
just know oh yeah like that you're like
that's sort of fancy people with you
fancy things I'm not I need a go be in
my pajamas that's like one example of
the behavior but it's more of like a
symbol for the whole culture right of
like the resort of the resort like not
Hawaii not Hawaii no I'm talking about
like resort life anywhere right
but like the dressing up for breakfast
and relaxing dressed up it was like 7:00
a.m. and there's people my god I'm like
what the [ __ ] dude what is going on like
I just want to wear my stupid sneakers
and my little shorts and my tank top and
just like have a good time and we felt
it felt out of place you know yeah there
was way too casual and I was like there
was this vacation we met one guy who I
really enjoyed talking to at the pool he
was really pleased from boston same age
as me yeah we talked for like an hour he
was there was honeymoon but like I felt
like that was the only time where we
kind of felt like we had anything in
common with someone yeah because the
rest of the time you're around a lot a
lot of them the people at the resort are
much older than us and they're retired
or whatever and aside from the people
that were obviously there as couples you
know for sure for sure
yeah and it's it was just like yeah
there was one moment where you felt like
oh we met someone we you know can talk
to him at least have a conversation with
the rest of it was like oh just keep to
ourselves
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
that's just the particular place that we
stayed because you walk plenty of other
places that didn't seem like that it
yeah yeah which is also why is beautiful
it's amazing and the humidity like just
made you realize just how [ __ ] dry it
is here how much is drying out
we're just drying it out do you wake up
you go outside
you your skin feels like hairs a little
moist and curly and I'm on an island
baby it was nice though like there are
things like that remembering how it
feels to walk around outside yeah
feeling the Sun like you know walking
around your flip-flops the soft sand on
the beach stuff like that like oh and
the Jenna was you were losing your mind
over the landscaping and all those
things that could grow all the plants
that people pay such good money for here
and on the internet they're just growing
in the ground yeah they were amazing but
yeah I think the best day that we had
was the day that we rented a car and we
got to go do our own thing and I think
in the future you know if we take
another vacation it probably you know I
don't think there's anything wrong with
Hawaii like I'd love to go back sometime
but like we'll probably do something you
know that makes more sense for us
because you know we don't we can't go
down to the nice restaurant and like eat
a nice dinner there so there's nothing
for us there to eat yeah like god forbid
we we rent to Airbnb we don't have some
of the amenities that a beautiful hotel
offers you but like we just cooked pad
thai every night and do our own thing
it's probably a vacation that makes more
sense for us in the future
for sure and I was I feel like it was a
super important first step as adults and
people who can do a better job of
maintaining their sanity while working a
lot yes yeah and we don't take enough
breaks we did it we did a really
important thing we took a vacation yeah
and it was for the most part really
great mm-hmm and I'm happy we did it and
yeah
we'll learn from it and make our next
vacation even better in doper yeah I
agree
yeah but I do think it's I always felt I
guess in my mind like I just like worked
through everything like I would just
push through you know a lot of time and
it felt like I would take breaks because
you know would have a day off of my
radio show because we're traveling to go
do this other thing and so you know I
just sort of pushed through the whole
year to get to those two weeks of
Christmas in New Year's and then those
two weeks come and it really doesn't
feel like a vacation at all and I don't
know just I think years went by like
that
and I don't think that there's anything
selfish about taking time for yourself
whereas I used to think it was something
really selfish you know no I don't think
it's selfish and I think it's important
and that that week really did a lot you
know and I I think we should keep doing
I think anyone should do it for sure
yeah yeah cuz I also remember to like
when I was a bartender and I was picking
up crazy hours and I was just working so
much and I had so many jobs and the
woman who trained me like my manager she
was like you know what are you doing for
the holidays like Thanksgiving and
Christmas and stuff and I was like well
I'm gonna be here you know I can work
any shifts you want me to work a mobile
block which is the shift that no one
wants to work exactly and she looked at
me and she was like you know you got to
take some time off and I was like I I
really can't afford it you know like I
have to work you know I need these
shifts and she was like yeah but
family's really important and like years
go by like years go by I'm looking her
and she's like in her mid-40s and she
was like listen to me like I was that
girl that worked through all of the
every holiday and everything and you
just like you miss out on so much life
we're like yeah you need that money but
you also need to see your family or like
you need to spend time with your loved
ones and you need to take time for
yourself and it's hard sometimes when
you can't financially afford to do that
for so many reasons but like it's I did
I think I wanted up taking off like a
day or something in there because it
just I don't know when somebody sort of
says that to you you're like [ __ ] man
okay right I'm missing out on my life
yeah I mean that's that's very wise and
I feel like you know it will apply to a
person at any stage in their life like
in some way right no matter what karat
is in front of you whether it's like you
can get these shifts and make more money
to be better off or it's like whatever
any situation there's an option to take
route a and work your ass off and not
pay attention to anything else or be and
slow down and look at life and have some
time with people and whatever so it's
that's super important it really is
mm-hmm
that's a that's a good memory to have I
feel like because that's that's the sort
of thing that just sticks with you yeah
you know what else sticks with you don't
me Andes something thick and thin me
Andes are there for you okay I took like
so many pairs of me and he's on vacation
and I spent so much time just on our
little hotel balcony and nothing but my
me and he's just looking at the whole is
true and the suns you did do you gotta
be bottomless to get to the top but
bottomless still means you have some me
undies on okay take off your pants when
you get it you get home take off your
pants relax that's why there's always
pants and socks all over our couch and
our downstairs you gotta be bottomless
it takes his pants off all the time yeah
cuz I want to just wear my immunities I
know that you can put your pants on the
stairs or something no move Liam hear me
undies are three times softer than
cotton made of micro modal fabric they
have new prints coming out all the time
they have onesies which are the most
comfortable onesie that you've ever
tried I promise and they have socks but
all that's a lot of stuff I'm telling
you it is so worth it we love that we
love them like crazy also if you would
like a gift for you and yours they do
couples pairing of mandy's where you can
get matching underwear which is really
cool it's like it's such a cool gift for
you and yours but right now go to me
undies comm slash Jenna Julianne get 15%
off your first pair of free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee or click the
link down below you will not be sorry I
promise
also guys check out the skim it's
completely free it is a really really
cool service sends in newsletter to your
inbox and your email every morning with
all the news that you need it's like all
the top headlines no nonsense no BS you
know it just tells you what you need to
know to be educated and it's free go to
the skin comm th es ki mmm calm as two
M's slash Jenna Julianne so you enter
your email and when you use that URL you
enter for a chance to win a $250 Visa
gift card
okay so whether you want to know about
Game of Thrones or
I don't know real-life news that's going
on in the world that you really should
be educated on the skin
will be there for you helping you out
stay in the know with the skin and also
guys Squarespace if you're looking to
build a website do the Squarespace they
make building a website so incredibly
easy and smooth and they have 24/7
award-winning customer support at any
point in the website building process if
you need someone to guide you through
something the customer support is there
for you use that for real like test it
out use our customer support is is very
very nice and helpful they also have
live chats and webinars live webinars on
Squarespace to show you how to do
different things you can customize your
website with all sorts of templates
mobile different templates desktop
tablet online stores shops fonts colors
whatever you want it to be you can make
it dream it do it with Squarespace go to
Squarespace comm slash Jen and Julian
for 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain or you can just check
out their free trial service if if you'd
like to do that as well click the link
below to get started thank you sponsors
what were you doing with his arm I was
kissing I will say it one thing that I
mean I know this about myself because
I'm just like we had a moment of
conversation when we were hanging out
and talking by the beach when we were
talking about friends and like you know
who you rely on for your emotional
support and that kind of thing and I
know about myself
that I rely so heavily for my emotional
needs on the dogs yeah how difficult it
is for me to not have any animal
interaction for a week just like I
talked to them like not in a I'm telling
you my problems just talking at them in
the most obnoxious voice I need their
love I need something to like take care
of you know it's like it's really
difficult for me to not have that you
know yeah I kind of feel like every dog
in some way is the therapy dog because
in a way unless you're me then your
karma therapy person no but they're your
therapy dogs I mean you literally just
grabbed therapy dog you get to have this
release of talking to them or touching
them or holding them and it helps you it
helps me a lot personally yes and we
were in a week without dogs we didn't
meet a cat a feral cat it just ran up to
me I was so excited on our last day we
were playing chess on the giant chess
board and all of a sudden this cat just
comes out of the bushes and starts
running anything like oh my god it's
like you knew I needed you today yeah we
were like we were actually just talking
about how much we missed not even our
dogs just dogs just any dog we just our
dog and a cat runs up to this little
courtyard that we're on and of course
Jenna like walks over to it's like hey
baby come here
and the thing like rolls on its side is
like okay Pet me now like the it was a
really sweet cat she was really willing
to like be loved I needed that though
yeah I really needed that we spent like
a couple hours over there I know well
because I don't know I I'm not a person
that needs like i confide in you and
like i talked to my mom you know i don't
need like a million friends I'm pretty
like independent and self sure in that
way but like I do absolutely this type
of relationship is something that
fulfills me a lot and not and I know
it's like a meme or like a joke but like
I'm actually and I think there's people
that exist that it just like you know
when you talk about a crazy cat lady
that just says like 50 cats but like
that's a funny joke but like that woman
is happy yeah you know maybe not 50
whatever the legal amount is to have but
like that it feels really good and for
some people it's just like I don't know
it's just a thing that's what I feel
like and when I don't have that for a
week it feels like an eternity and I
feel like a part of me just like isn't
happy
yeah my mom knew that about me when I
was little too which is why she wouldn't
let me get a dog or a cat but she would
always let me have like a gerbil or
hamster or something because I just
liked it it does a lot for me you are a
person that needs needs that first need
a sense yeah I mean you need it and then
you also have this like urge to take
care of it yeah you know other things
too that I just for money unit
but let's talk about Bunny House Bunny
doing I know I gave like you know a two
second update in my videos we talked a
little bit on stream but we went to go
pick her up at her foster home which
again that man is a saint he he was
taking care of multiple gray house he
have what four when she was there he had
one named Tom and Tom and bunny by the
way I'm learning you know and I know
this is probably customized or unique
circumstance for everyone who has a
foster pet who are adopted a pet from a
foster home or whatever but I'm
realizing that that guy is going to be
playing a pretty decently sized role in
our and our dog's life yeah and it's
pretty special how that relationship
yeah that's really special yeah I know
Jeff's dog Jolene is like that too
because I'm always like Jeff if you have
a need someone watched Jolene just let
me know and he's always like yeah her
foster moms taking her I'm like [ __ ] she
always wins obviously cuz they will they
love they love everyone yeah well I mean
when you have a dog that's like and her
foster dad is sort of expressed that
about her that she's just like really
sweet and really wonderful and if you're
a your fostering dogs and you have a dog
like that you you sort of can only hope
that they are like you want to watch her
for a little cuz then you don't ever
really say goodbye yeah you know you get
the best of both you say see you later
see you next time yeah so it was a
little we're a little scared obviously
to pick her up because the first two
weeks that we had her were hard and like
difficult and that's when all of the
everything was just every day every hour
was a lot it was really difficult in 24
hours yes and then we were gonna go pick
her up and we were like you know what's
gonna happen
is she gonna remember us is she gonna
feel trauma now that she's been two
weeks at our house she spent six days
she was only with her foster dad for six
days before we got her so like that's
really not enough time for her to
acclimate to being a dog whatsoever nor
to him or whatever and then we only had
her for two weeks and then she went back
to her foster home for
one week so I mean it's kind of a
mindfuck right like she doesn't know
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah and we
were nervous and when I brought her to
the faucet she was crying she really
before vacation she's gonna fit yeah
because I we had driven her before and I
never heard that sort of like cry I
think she thought she was going back
right and that's you know every night
when we put her in her crate she's
really good about going in but sometimes
she doesn't want to come out and it's
like I think she has she likes the crate
it makes her feel safe but I think
there's a part of her obviously that's
like well maybe if I go in here or if I
go in the car it means I'm never coming
back and I don't want to do that you
know I think she just has you know a lot
of complex emotions happening sometimes
for sure about what's happening and we
were like you know she's gonna remember
us are we gonna go back to square one
with her with the house and we were
prepared I was fully mentally prepared
to just relive the first two weeks again
with her and we go to her foster dad's
house it's like 8:00 in the morning 7:00
7:00 in the morning and we go in and we
see his two foster dogs and their big
horse boys his dogs Hey yeah and we're
like okay where's the little girl at I
like looked in the corner of living her
where she normally says she wasn't there
where is she she's outside so we walk
outside and she she jumps on Julian's
like shoulders cuz you bent down she
jumped on your shoulders and gave you a
kiss and hugged me she posed if she like
did this really slow like jump where she
put her paws on my shoulders but she had
never done before and I'm like sitting
there experiencing and I'm like oh my
god she's hugging me and then she kisses
me and face a couple times and I was
like I was like ready to cry oh my god I
can't believe it I know and then she
went over and kissed you and she kissed
me tuned I was like not only can I like
release the anxiety of her that I had of
her not remembering me or whatever but I
got a kiss she not missed us I know he
like was excited to see us remember who
I am and then she did it again a couple
days later I came home from jujitsu she
jumped up and hugged and kissed me I was
like oh my god I know our trainer came
over today and she he like bent down
because she's really only met Rome then
she met my friend Rachel
charli's they were in town and then she
met our trainer Dustin and Carolyn when
they came over and so what she's only
met five people in her house and she's
like super nice and friendly and excited
yeah she's really good and so Dustin
bent down to meet her and she did the
hug I was like aw Julie and I don't know
if we should eat or how to do this alarm
me she likes men she likes men yes she
did it - yes a general saying our
trainer our trainers came over today
they're husband and wife and yeah I
think she likes I think she looks to a
strong male presence she because her
foster dad is a guy in your guy and you
know we both you know she just likes
calm guy energy I think that's a girl
dog thing - well depends it depends I
mean you look at my mom's and sisters
dogs those are females that love being
around females so yeah yeah so she's I
mean but then so we drove her home yeah
you know we're like okay she remembered
us that's great but now you know what if
she we get back into the house and it's
she doesn't remember that she's so
afraid and just leaving for a week the
time that she spent at her foster home
was like she made leaps and bounds she
was ready to walk in the door she didn't
hesitate when she walked in the front
door like she stopped just running to
her bed in the corner our dogs did a
good job remembering who she was and
like there was no big like oh we got to
calm this down it was like everything
was fine and she all of a sudden felt
like a dog like she was acting like a
dog yeah you know I could not believe
that because for those first two weeks
she would just either go in her bed in
the living room in her bed in the stream
room or outside on the pool chair or her
dog bed out there and she would really
just sort of stay there or pace a little
and then lay down but like there was no
real interaction it felt like when you
were talking to her she wasn't really
responding she wasn't really like
interacting with you it was like if you
have food yeah or otherwise
listen to your talk and she would still
get scared by noises in the kitchen or
anywhere outside she was like violently
opposed to the construction going on the
first couple weeks and then all of a
sudden when we got her it was like she
was being a dog you know like she could
just relax like I think that week with
those other big dogs in a house it
helped a lot and how like these guys had
a little break and and then when they
all got reunited again it was not nearly
as bad as I was prepared for I think we
got really lucky in that yeah well you
know it was tough because the first two
weeks they were probably the hardest two
weeks ever yeah they were very hard
night and day we were stressed we were
concerned we were really really putting
a lot of effort in time and working on
her and I'm sure she's learning things
and understanding us and seeing that not
everything's gonna get her in she she
would react erratically to things
sometimes which is hardly that's what
makes you want to edge a little bit it's
like what's her trigger like what is it
exactly and I think too like a lot of
people can relate to getting a timid
rescue dog and having that be a thing
but the size discrepancy and her also
being unpredictable and her reactions
with the little dogs is what put us in
like survival mode literally because you
can't take your eyes away you don't know
what's gonna happen yeah any little
sound you're like okay what who's you
know right she starts running and then
one of them starts running and then she
yeah it's like it gets really scary and
0-200 really fast yeah and so like the
first two weeks we were just in the
thick of that where it was like fight or
flight for two weeks well because they
she had growled at a couple of them and
that's fine their dogs but like we don't
know what that escalates into but now
we're like we're getting to know her in
her reactions and it feels so much more
comfortable I don't think anything bad
is gonna happen in our current situation
would and and like you go from like an
experience like that where you've taken
a rescue dog
and you can do all the preparing you
want but at the end of the day that dog
is that dog and it's a unique situation
it's come from and they might have weird
little triggers or things that you have
to do and discover as they come right
and so like you know going from that
initial period where we were just trying
so hard to like love her and I gotta be
honest like the first week that we had
her she did not feel like my dog I
didn't at all and I was giving her love
and I was so excited to have her she was
a big dog it was exciting but at no
point did I feel like I love this dog
and she's my dog that took a little bit
of time because I was looking after her
I was her caretaker we were her
caretakers but I don't have a bond
there's no bond yeah and so coming home
I feel like we were just kind of flooded
with the fruits of our labor
yes which we hadn't seen yet yeah and
that was really special yeah and it made
both of us feel like not only like
amazing right like this is this big dog
that we've been hugging and kissing and
getting nothing back for so long but it
just felt like okay we're doing things
right she understands that we're here
for her she trusts us she appreciates us
and now we can start working on just
like being a dog but it was the first
time though that we came home from out
of town and our three little ones are
there and we're so excited we're having
our like you know moment of being
reunited and I we both felt [ __ ]
incomplete I was like usually this is
when I'm like oh my god we're home
missed you guys like I feel so good now
and I didn't get that feeling until we
got bunny so like even though in your
mind it's like the bond is missing and
it does still sometimes feel like I'm
just taking care of you and we're not
like in this like loving bonding
relationship it it there was a hole in
your heart that's like there's somebody
missing until tomorrow until we pick her
up in the morning yeah yeah yeah so yeah
I mean but now she very much feels like
her dog she does every little every day
there's little improvements but for the
most part like you know it's sucked when
like her only presence in our house was
like you said pacing from one end to
another to her bed
to her water to outside now she'll just
walk around she'll just go and sniff
some things and we are still dealing
with the Yaya's we try our best men to
get her tired during the day she will
Malak that girl will molasses her ass on
a walk we'll go for a walk not even that
long and all of a sudden she starts
[ __ ] dragging ass and I'm like let's
go let's go she's just lazy and then at
like 10:00 p.m. not even telling sheet
and then 10 days yeah red in the stream
room because we're trying to get her
used to the routine and some days she
still is doing a little bit of the I'm
not ready to get my crate I'm tired I'm
lazy and we'll have to coax her out with
food to try and get her going to get
some of her energy out during the day
and Julian all run with her and I'll
play with a toy and backyard which by
the way she has at least outside and we
did it really diligently and carefully
with the resource guarding with the toy
I can now play with a toy with her
outside in the yard and she is so good
about it and she's no longer she's my
resource guarding she she'll I don't
know about with the other dogs yet we
haven't tried that but with person and
in the house within her bed she can have
a toy if the other dogs aren't near her
yeah in the yard well I think in general
like having a big dog and little dogs I
don't think it's a common thing for
someone to want to play with one toy
with multiple sized dogs so that doesn't
need to be a goal for us that's insane
but she like you said she's playing with
the toy outside she like throws it up to
herself she's so derpy it's hilarious
get her tired right yeah and then at 10
p.m. she gets out of her bench starts
barking at us yes she we don't speak the
same language yet sometimes we don't
know if it's I'm thirsty bark if it's I
need to go outside so we try a little
bit of everything right we try and
discover what it is it's usually I want
Julian to run in the yard so I can chase
him but you're streaming or you're busy
we're trying to get her into the idea
that like you got to get all your Yaya's
out by you know 7:00 p.m. you got a nice
chunk of the day where the door is open
we're here we go for a nice long walk
you can play we're here to play with you
but there is no 10:00 p.m. Yaya time do
not and if we're eating at the kitchen
table she's
pretty good she'll come up you know
she's a dog that doesn't understand the
word know so she wants to smell your
food you say no this is my food not for
you you know and she'll sort of back off
but if we eat in the game room she
throws a [ __ ] tantrum they're a whole
ass tantrum she'll bark she gets really
frustrated yeah she starts doing this
thing where she was like this yeah well
she does the little like she's like but
it's like it's it turns into this funny
like we're actually learning you know
when she throws her little tantrums if
we ignore her it does the best cuz she
does she's not getting any reaction
she's like I might as well go back to my
bed but it is there gets to be a pretty
funny back-and-forth which he's like
doesn't get it doesn't know what I'm
saying so she just thinks I'm like
barking back at her and it just turns
out to be so funny but it's so endearing
and honestly as much as it's like a
little bit of a nuisance sometimes with
the loud dog barks well speaking of loud
she set off our house alarm because she
barked so loud yeah yeah but what my
point is that it doesn't mean she's
opening up totally way more comfortable
and yeah but yeah we yes we haven't
really left her for morning we've been
doing the 30 minutes we're trying to
work up to like an hour two hours three
hours for us so we've done 10 minutes
then we did 10 minutes a couple times as
like a test we went out in the front
yard we pretended we weren't here you
know that was that but two days ago
actually Wednesday video day we had to
go to the beauty supply store I'm going
to get prosthetics and so we thought
this would be a good time to do a 30
minute leave we left her in her crate
set the little camera and we use a Kong
like there was a YouTube videos really
helpful where you mix their food with a
little water and then you freeze it and
then you cover the top with peanut
butter when you're ready to give it to
them so that it takes a little while for
them really good helpful video first we
did it several times at home first and
you know the first time it was like she
had it like five minutes licked the
peanut butter off then she was ready and
we were trying to nerd downstairs cry
and she's now she's yelling she
digging in her bed she's like ready to
get out so then we worked up to ten then
he worked up a little bit and then we
left the house so Wednesday we needed to
pull the trigger because we needed to
leave obvious I mean you have to be able
to leave we have to leave our house like
in essence like you know we had been
faking it till we're making it so like I
would go to jujitsu and come back and
then I'm so you might have to run
somewhere and come back but it's like
one of us is always here right so we're
like let's both do this we'll keep the
camera on hold over the Kong she set the
alarm off ATT's calling Julian they're
like you want us to send the cops off
our alarm system goes off because I
didn't realize I shouldn't have armed
the alarm but I always do it so I'm like
you know what I know and so I get a call
from you know oh the your alarms off and
I was like wait a minute
cuz this has happened before where our
gardener had the loudly calm like weed
whacker a window it like it gives a
certain frequency that that the alarm
system recognizes and sets it off it
sounds like do you have a sound based
alarm in that room and they were like
yes any loud noises were set up I was
like okay don't send the cops like turn
off dessert so I drove home it was bunny
she had set off our alarm and we had a
camera setup so we knew she was Barbie
tissue and we heard the alarm yeah but
it was a little hectic but you know she
was good she survived she didn't hurt
herself she didn't go to the bathroom in
her crazy hangout she's barking she was
a little nervous a little frantic lucky
but chewing on the Kong enjoying that
she did that for the longest she's ever
done which means we're building up in
time yeah and then she would lay down
for a little bit then she would stand up
and bark and then she would lay down
then shoot you the talk the Kong it was
like a little rotation until she set the
alarm off and then everybody was free
yeah all the dogs are free and like we
wouldn't have done this on the first
time ever but if we were to
hypothetically have left her for like
three hours at a time all of a sudden
she is an incredible self soother she
will bark and be scared but at the end
of the day she knows how to soothe
situation lay down yeah I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna cry I'm gonna circle around
and lay down that's what she does
sometimes that's what she did when we
first got her she would cry and cry and
cry and then lay down that was like her
routine and so it was like part of her
self soothing which is really
for her to like know how to do not that
we're giving him a sort of disarm it's
not a destructive self no it's a very
like a healthy version of it right but
yeah so that's kind of like the update
of where we are with her now yeah she's
been left alone for 30 minutes in her
crate we literally can't really we we
left the house we drove a bunch of miles
away like five five ish miles away like
we did it we really left her it wasn't
it go get some frosted yeah but it felt
good because it wasn't like a fake test
where we could run in the front door
from the front you're at any moment it
was like we really trusted her and it
turned out well so yeah and she's here
in the podcast room she's she goes up
the stairs down the stairs and sometimes
she likes to be helped up the second
part of the stairs I can't believe she's
sitting in here and it's cuz we just
went for a walk so she's a little tired
but she's been really good about just
chillin which is why we love greyhounds
they're the laziest breed of dog person
these ones included they're just so lazy
we're do this thing like they they
deserve a walk they appreciate a walk
but they also just want to [ __ ] lay
around yeah they're great things are
going really well in the dog arena and
we've been we've been back like you know
live on Twitch almost all the nights so
usually we have a bunny cam set up so
you can actually see her live on stream
and watch us struggle rather to know
whether she's sleeping peacefully or
whether she's throwing a tantrum or
whatever it is yeah we have it it's made
the streams quite interesting and that's
for sure well it gets tricky too because
if we're both obviously gaming there's
been a couple times when we're just like
oh my god cuz it'll be like an hour
well she'll start barking and what you
know we take her outside we do a little
play and then we come in see if she
needs water did you go to the bathroom
like here do you want like a little
treat like something like whatever
whatever it is you need attention we
try and exhaust all the options about
what's what's causing her to get up and
bark and get excited and then if we do
all of that she doesn't respond and it's
like okay now we ignore her but
sometimes it takes her like a full hour
to decide that she's gonna settle but
I'm like baby girl we got you tired
today I know that you got enough
exercise today you got all of your
Yaya's out this is now the time when you
need to learn you can't get up barking
people that go sprint outside you know
yeah that's so funny man it's funny cuz
in a lot of ways she's she acts the same
way that a puppy does yeah because she
doesn't know any commands and she's
excitable and you know she doesn't she
acts like a puppy but she's [ __ ]
enormous he's big she's huge
we should weigh her dude it is very
exactly well you know the night that we
got peach and she kept crawling into
your pizza box and you're pushing her
away and you're like no and she doesn't
get it she's like oh must get to pee
here I go here I go like the more you
push her away than where she's like I
still want it I'm gonna keep going doing
that with a gigantic dog it's the same
thing it's just she's huge and she'll
bark at you the entire time like a
piercing loud bark so loud will it will
set off your home alarm I had to mute
the stream although you you just mean a
thing that says bunnies bar yeah we need
like a little graphic to where I can
press a button so we are subject you
guys are loud barking yeah it'll mute my
mic you know give you like a flashing
warning she's parking but yeah that's
kind of what's what's been our life the
last couple of weeks since you've seen
us but everything's really good we had a
really good vacation it was really good
to have time off yeah thank you guys for
allowing us to do that we really
appreciate it
so much and things with bunny are going
you know better than we had prepared for
much much better and things just in
general with all of them were in a good
place
yeah so all of your messages and you
know nice things that you've said I've
been really nice to hear so thank you
and we'll keep you updated we promise
you'll see you're on stream
iishe look again I can't believe she sat
here for the entire podcast that's like
true Greyhound [ __ ]
just lay next to you well eventually
yeah yeah not if it's 10:00 p.m. and
we're live on Twitch I know do we need
to change our streams good work time
like bass our stream schedule around
when she's come no she's got a little
routine so we're nice anyway thank you
guys for hanging out and listening to
another episode of gems we broadcast
we'll be back next week for more
podcasts in action and we'll be live on
Twitch all week so we'll see you there
and see you then be good
[Music]